they are continuing to attack dr anthony
fauci they want to see him in prison
many of them do
for what crime we don't really know and
the latest is that donald trump's former
economic advisor
peter navarro says that he will force
fauci to admit that he created covid now
how that if it's the china virus as they
say
and china created it
how is it that fauci created it it
doesn't really make sense we're going to
look at this clip and consider how
extreme
how dangerous
how disturbing it is
that
they want to go after
medical doctors who just give us their
best advice at the time these are sick
people here's peter navarro on newsmax
listen to this here's your future tony
republicans are gonna sweep and take the
house back from nancy pelosi and as soon
as that happens you're gonna sit your
ass down in a chair
in congress
and you're going to confess
to
creating the virus that's killed almost
a million americans now all on your
watch sir
and then we're going gonna figure out
he's talking about fouchy again just as
a reminder all the special deals you had
with all those grant money things and um
we're gonna fit you for an orange
jumpsuit tony you can count on that so
so don't be smug on cnn dude
okay so this is all a reaction to a
comment that dr fauci recently made dr
fauci was asked you know he served uh
under donald trump
um he was made chief medical advisor
under joe biden and he was asked if
trump comes back in 2024
would you serve under trump and fouchy
essentially said no now i actually think
that it's sort of a non-question anthony
fauci is now uh what is he is he 81
uh he's 81 years old uh if and when
trump comes back he would be close to 85
years old i anticipate that dr fauci is
going to be retiring in the next few
years so at the end of the day i don't
really believe it's even a choice dr
fauci will would be making
will i or won't i stay under donald
trump i could be wrong but it is to some
degree a political statement i mean dr
fauji is saying it was so crazy trying
to deal with covet under trump that if
trump comes back i'm out that's fine why
is the right obsessed with going after
medical doctors
well one of the answers is their
political ideology that they espouse
since the start of the pandemic be very
skeptical of vaccines be skeptical of
masks be skeptical of whether staying
away from people physically even really
prevents the spread of the virus being
skeptical about the fact that this is
much more deadly than the flu all of
these different things all of the
political position all of the medical
positions that they staked out were not
really medical positions they weren't
really science-based positions they were
political positions made to perpetuate
their own ideology of so-called freedom
and all these different things and to
make donald trump's failed response look
less bad or to even look good if you can
imagine it and so when that's the
political position that you stake out
you have to make those
who have a different view your enemies
and the medical science community had a
different view the medical science
community had views that differed about
guidelines safety guidelines vaccines
masking all these different things and
so you have to make them your enemies
and that is a it's a feature rather than
a bug of modern reactionary politics
it's not just you know we kind of have
like a different perspective about
the correct level of taxes or whatever
the case may be which is like okay well
we can disagree
but it's not
as i mean
i would argue it's pretty clear
what is better economically when it
comes to taxes but there is more of like
an ideology associated with it and the
spirit of what the government should be
doing in terms of taxation okay with a
lot of these coveted related things it's
just the science that's all it is and
when you are
basing your politics on reactionary
fear-mongering and
arguing that those with a different view
are evil and on and on and on when
that's your perspective
you have to attack everybody and make
everybody your enemy and so doctors
become your enemy and that's exactly
what we're seeing now i want to go back
to the obvious hypocrisy
trump called it the china virus china
did it china created it but at the same
time they want to blame dr fauci it
seems like hypocrisy but remember
hypocrisy has no bottom or no top i
guess depending on your perspective with
the modern right wing so what will they
come up with i am sure that they will
say well no
fouchy
had
and funded
china creating it
that's how they will square the two uh
peter navarro really makes
my pillow mike lindell
seem like kind of a reasonable guy he
makes him seem almost sane and the
really scary part is that the rhetoric
is becoming more overtly violent
even now talking about
imprisoning
or going after medical doctors and
they're doing it all out in the open
it's becoming normal it's
extraordinarily unsettling how
comfortable the modern american right is
with threats of violence threats of
suspending due process and just just
jail people just put them in jail very
very scary stuff